you
a lower GI endoscopy also called
colonoscopy or sigmoidoscopy allows your
doctor to view the mucosal lining of
your lower gastrointestinal tract
the procedure is used as a screening
test in individuals with no symptoms or
to help diagnose unexplained abdominal
pain rectal bleeding or change in bowel
habits
it is capable of detecting inflammation
infections ulcers diverticulosis
intestinal narrowing colorectal polyps
cancer or other problems that may be
present
the procedure is performed using an
endoscope which is a long thin flexible
tube with a light and tiny video camera
attached to the end the camera transmits
an image to a monitor in a sigmoidoscopy
the endoscope only reaches to the top of
the descending colon
in a colonoscopy the endoscope reaches
through the entire length of the colon
to where it connects to the small
intestine
before a colonoscopy an intravenous line
will be started and you'll be offered
pain medication and de sedative your
blood pressure pulse and the oxygen
level in your blood will be monitored
and you may also receive oxygen through
a nasal cannula during the procedure a
sigmoidoscopy does not usually require
this kind of preparation or monitoring
the presence of the endoscope and the
air may cause you to feel cramping or
pressure and the need to pass gas this
is considered a normal part of the
procedure your doctor may ask you to
change your position slightly to help
maneuver the endoscope more easily
through the curves of your lower
intestine
if you experience pain tell your doctor
immediately in some cases your doctor
may find it necessary to take a biopsy a
biopsy helps distinguish between benign
and cancerous tissues and can help
determine the cause of bleeding
inflammation or diarrhea biopsies are
often taken even when your doctor does
not suspect cancer if one or more polyps
are discovered your doctor will
generally remove them in a procedure
called a Polly Peck t'me he or she will
usually use a snare to remove the polyps
and then cauterize their bases to
control bleeding after the procedure you
will be monitored for about a half an
hour until the effects of any
medications you have taken wear off you
will need to arrange for a ride home
particularly after a full colonoscopy